[Music]
I see you in school and I don't say how
pleased not to get personal okay
really your nice boy and everything it's
okay
[Music]
that is a teenage Diane Lane in the cult
classic The Outsiders the actress
received an Oscar nomination for
unfaithful and has also starred in
movies like the perfect storm in Justice
League Lane is a new cast member on the
very popular Netflix series house of
cards the show revealed last month that
Kevin Spacey's character Francis
Underwood is dead following the actors
exit from the series so lanes were
Trey's Annette who runs her family's
powerful conglomerate and as a shared
history with the new president that's
Claire underwood whatever Francis
promised or did is buried with him no I
know we all need to let him go start
from some kind of scratch so it must
haunt you the fact that he died next to
you in bed Oh Diane Lane joins us at the
table such a [ __ ] she's an art
character but it was like oh you are a
Diane Lane oh I know it's called acting
typecasting acting but tell us about
your character because she and Robin
right she and Clara Underwood have
history the two of them that is true we
actually get to see some lovely young
actresses portray us in high school
years and we see some of their backstory
I mean when you know somebody from that
time you definitely have a little dirt
on them and horribly yeah and you know
we maximize weaponizing it should but
this is a thing you already you you guys
were already filming this this series
and these episodes when we got word that
Kevin Spacey would no longer be part of
the cast did you think oh no it's going
to be over did you think the show would
be canceled well everybody knows exactly
where they were when they heard the news
that was involved with the show where
we'd already been filming I was filming
on another show called the Romanovs
which is opening same the same time for
me and it was a big scene we were in a
church and everybody's
staring at me and talking and they're
looking at their phones and at a certain
moment I started to feel paranoid I
didn't know what was going on and they
all came over to me and suddenly one was
brave enough to say yeah the show has
been canceled and I said excuse me
because headlines are like that now
they're very hyper hyperbolized yes for
bollocks yeah yeah yeah and exaggerated
and it wasn't cancelled but it threw
everybody into a panic because it's such
a beloved show and it was very dramatic
news and of course we wound up going on
hiatus and the writers did a beautiful
job you wondering how it could continue
well I mean my joke has been if you can
make a joke about anything as grave as
that I mean how do you do a show about
Godzilla but you can't see Godzilla and
you know it was an extraordinary game of
Jenga for the writers to achieve you
know how the how they at the core of the
show this essential thing is the
backbiting the backstabbing that
Incredibles hammy saw of you which is
cold steely knife shipping is that
what's at the center of this and if so
what does that say about us well it's
funny I don't know with the zeitgeist of
current events and politics and this
show having used to be so shocking and
now the writers have to and they have
successfully exceeded the headlines
which I mean that's an achievement so
you had me at Romanovs oh obsessed with
the Russian royal family oh well that
was before the Russian Revolution and
this Amazon series is about a bunch of
different characters yes I think that
they're all long-lost descendants of the
family correct about that well you know
it's it's the story of humanity it's a
story of people who their families
they're all they're interspersed all
over the world they don't necessarily
know about one another and each show is
a little movie and Matthew Winer is so
gifted as a writer and director on this
of course it's his vision and I can't
wait to find out what the threat is that
connects all these stories but I know
that each one is delicious and it's fun
not knowing what to expect and it's fun
having a fresh cast it's a different way
it's appointment television
what's old is new again in terms of
appointment television ah
yeah be good to be Diane Lane you've got
to hit series going on the same time
that's pretty graduation Diane thank you
thank you coming from you that's quite a
compliment me on I was talking about you
we said we remember you and unfaithful
and she said she was effortlessly
beautiful and that's so condemning day
yeah Oh effortless yes I woke up like
this
thank you congratulations
no I'm so grateful to work with
wonderful people and I'm so proud and
joyful over Robin Wright successful yeah
yeah I'll so excited for you fed a new
episode of the Romanovs is available
this Friday on Amazon that's also when
the final season of house of cards
premieres on Netflix